De hecho, es más grande que los Boy Scouts de EE. UU.
Y no somos homofóbicos.
(Risas)
Y es verdad... nos comunicamos con los jóvenes con texto,
porque eso es como se comunica la gente joven.
Vamos a realizar más de 200 campañas este año,
cosas como recoger mantequilla de maní para las despensas de alimentos,
o hacer tarjetas de San Valentín para los jubilados que están confinados en casa.
Y les enviaremos mensajes.
Y tendremos una tasa de apertura del 97 %..
Irá sobre el índice en hispanos y urbanos.
Recogimos 200 000 frascos de mantequilla de maní
y más de 365 mil tarjetas de San Valentín.
Es a gran escala. Bien...
(Aplausos)
Pero hay un efecto secundario raro.
Cada vez que enviamos un mensaje de texto,
recibimos algunos mensajes que no tienen nada que ver con mantequilla de maní,
hambre o la tercera edad,
sino con mensajes de texto sobre intimidación,
mensajes de texto sobre ser adictos.
Y el peor mensaje que jamás recibimos decía exactamente esto:
"No va a dejar de violarme.
Es mi padre.
Me dijo que no se lo diga a nadie. ¿Estás ahí?".
No podíamos creer lo que sucedía.
No podíamos creer que algo tan horrible le pudiera pasar a un ser humano,
y que ella lo compartiera con nosotros... algo tan íntimo, tan personal.
Y vimos que teníamos que dejar de clasificarlo
y construir una línea de texto de crisis para estas personas sufriendo.
Así lanzamos Línea de Texto para Crisis,
sin ruido, en Chicago y El Paso, solo unas pocas miles de personas en cada mercado.
Y en 4 meses, estábamos en todos los 295 códigos de área en EE. UU.
Solo para ponerlo en perspectiva,
eso es cero mercadeo y un crecimiento superior al lanzamiento de Facebook.
(Aplausos)
El texto es increíblemente privado.
Nadie te oye hablar.
Nos clavamos todos los días al almuerzo...
los niños sentados en la mesa
y uno piensa que ella está enviando mensajes al chico lindo,
pero en realidad nos envía un texto sobre su bulimia.
Y no tenemos un "like" o "um" o hiperventilación o llanto.
Solo conseguimos hechos.
Tenemos cosas como: "Quiero morir.
Tengo una botella de píldoras en la mesa delante de mí".
Y así, el consejero de crisis, dice,
"¿Pon esas pastillas en el cajón mientras escribes?".
Y van y vienen por un tiempo.
Y el consejero consigue que la chica que le dé su dirección,
porque si envías mensajes a una línea, deseas ayuda.
Escribe la dirección
y el consejero desencadena un rescate activo
mientras envían mensajes uno a otro.
Y luego se queda en silencio...
23 minutos sin respuesta por parte de esta chica.
Y el siguiente mensaje que llega dice
--es la madre--
"No tenía ni idea y yo estaba en la casa,
estamos en una ambulancia de camino al hospital".
Como madre uno solo...
El siguiente mensaje llega un mes después.
"Acabo de salir del hospital.
Fui diagnosticada como bipolar, y creo que me pondré bien".
(Aplausos)
Me encantaría decirles que este es un intercambio inusual,
pero estamos haciendo un promedio de 2.41 rescates activos al día.
El 30 % de nuestros mensajes son suicidio y depresión... enorme.
Lo bonito de la Línea de Texto de Crisis
es que estos son extraños aconsejando a otros extraños
sobre los temas más íntimos,
y convirtiendo momentos calientes en fríos.
Es emocionante, y yo les diría
que hemos gestionado un total de más de 6.5 millones de mensajes de texto
en menos de 2 años.
(Aplausos)
Pero lo que realmente me pone hace sudar con todo esto,
lo que realmente me enloquece son los datos:
6.5 millones de mensajes,
es el volumen, la velocidad y la variedad para ofrecer un corpus muy jugoso.
Podemos hacer trabajo predictivo.
Podemos sacar todo tipo de conclusiones y aprendizajes a partir de esos datos.
Así que podemos ser mejores, y el mundo puede ser mejor.
¿Cómo se utilizan los datos para hacernos mejores?
Bien, lo más probable es que alguien aquí, viendo esto,
haya visitado un terapeuta o un psiquiatra en algún momento en su vida...
no tienen que levantar la mano.
(Risas)
¿Cómo saben que esa persona es buena?
Ah, ¿tienen un grado de Harvard en la pared?
¿Están seguros de que no se graduó en el 10 % inferior?
(Risas)
Cuando con mi marido fuimos a un consejero matrimonial,
pensé que era un genio cuando dijo:
"Los veré en 2 semanas... pero señor, necesito verlo la próxima semana".
(Risas)
Tenemos los datos para saber lo que hace un gran consejero.
Sabemos que si envían las palabras "adormecido" y "manga"
hay un de 99 % de que se corten.
Sabemos que si envía en texto las palabras "mg" y "goma elástica"
hay un 99 % para abuso de sustancias.
Y sabemos que si envía "sexo", "oral" y "mormón"
se está cuestionando si es gay.
Esa es información interesante que un consejero puede averiguar
pero nuestro algoritmo hace que unas ventanas emergentes digan:
"99 % para cortes, intente hacer una de estas preguntas"
para afinar al consejero.
O "99 % para el abuso de sustancias,
aquí hay 3 clínicas de drogas cerca del redactor de textos".
Nos hace más precisos.
El día en que Robin Williams se suicidó,
se inundaron las líneas en todo el país.
Fue triste ver a un icono, un comediante, que se suicida,
y hubo tiempos de 3 horas de espera en cada línea telefónica en el país.
Tuvimos un aumento en volumen también.
La diferencia fue
que si su texto era, "Quiero morir", o "Quiero matarme"
el algoritmo lee eso, lo pone en código naranja,
y lo convierte en número uno en la cola.
Así que podemos manejar por gravedad, no cronológicamente.
(Aplausos)
Estos datos también están haciendo un mundo mejor
porque estoy sentada en el primer mapa mundial de crisis en tiempo real.
Piensen en ello:
los 6.5 millones de mensajes, etiquetados a través de procesos de lenguaje natural,
todos estos puntos de datos...
les puedo decir el peor día para trastornos alimentarios: el lunes.
El peor momento del día para el abuso de sustancias: 5 am.
Y que Montana es un lugar hermoso para visitar
pero uno no quiere vivir allá,
porque es el estado número uno para la ideación suicida.
Y hemos hecho públicos estos datos, gratuita y abiertamente.
Hemos quitado toda información de identificación personal.
Y es un lugar llamado CrisisTrends.org.
Porque quiero que las escuelas puedan ver
que el lunes es el peor día para los trastornos alimentarios,
para que puedan planificar las comidas
y tener orientadores los lunes.
Quiero que las familias puedan ver que el pico de abuso de sustancias es las 5 am.
Quiero a alguien para cuidar de esas Reservas Indígenas en Montana.
(Aplausos)
Datos, evidencia
hacer política, investigación,
periodismo, policía, consejos escolares... todo mejor.
No creo en mí misma como un activista de salud mental.
Pienso en mí misma como un activista nacional de salud.
Me entusiasmo mucho con estos datos; soy un poco nerd.
Sí, eso sonó demasiado femenino.
Soy nerd.
(Risas)
Me encantan los datos.
Y la única diferencia realmente entre yo y esa gente en sudaderas en la vía
con sus empresas de capital de grasa,
es que no me inspira ayudarle a encontrar comida china a las 2 am en Dallas,
o ayudar a chasquear los dedos y obtener un auto de inmediato,
o pasarla bien y acostarte.
Estoy inspirada...
(Risas, aplausos)
quiero utilizar la tecnología y los datos para hacer del mundo un lugar mejor.
Quiero ayudar a esa chica,
que envió un texto sobre haber sido violada por su padre.
Porque no hemos escuchado más de ella.
Y espero que ella esté en algún lugar seguro y saludable,
y espero que ella vea esta charla
y sepa que su desesperación
y su coraje inspiró la creación de la Línea de Texto de Crisis
y me inspira cada maldito día.
(Aplausos)